This is how you end a day, properly...
...after traveling for 24 straight hours. 😴
(uhhh)
♫ (upbeat hip-hop intro) ♫
Just flew a...took a red-eye ✈
after last night's event in LA.
Connected in Dallas.
Landed here in Naples,
Fort Meyers area.
Just did a client pitch.
Looks like we won it,
which is exciting.
Big 'get' for Vayner.
Big brand. Exciting.
I'm happy about it. 😊
Now heading back to the airport.
Connecting into Chicago,
and getting back to LA.
Just a really intense 22 hours or so.
Last night's event in LA was extraordinary.
Never had an event that had
2,000 people show up for it.
Just wanted to thank everybody in LA.
So humbled.
4 hours of photos and selfies and
signings and answering business questions.
It's just such an incredible
ego boost as you can imagine.
Just a vibe ... a positive vibes boost.
It's ego boost and it's humility at the same time.
And then, just loving the kind
of life I'm living right now
where I can have that kind of moment,
and I can rush to the airport.
Take 4 flights in 22 hours
to do a business pitch
where you're just a person
pitching the business.
You're a low man on the totem pole
trying to get that nut.
I love that balance of push-and--pull.
I love shooting for the stars,
and digging the ditches.
I really want that balance of ego and humility.
Rock stardom and  just another
salesperson trying to make it happen.
...I think there's some
health in those polar opposites.
Having the humility to know
that you're not shit,
and having the confidence
to know that you're special.
Important.
.
(In French accent)
On a plane.  ✈
Just landed in Chicago now.
On another plane from Chicago to LA.
Wanted to describe some my social media today.
Sometimes I just gotta sub-tweet.
Just kind of random ideas or thoughts
or add something to my story
that has no context...
just little fun for myself.
Think we all kind of do that.
↖️The one that goes right here is about...
.
It's not scary selling stuff.
It's scary selling stuff you don't believe in.
So many people ask me about
"How do I sell?" "How do I sell?"
I poke... I poke... to try to figure out,why?
Are they insecure?
Do they just not have it?
Stunning, the amount of people
just selling shit they don't believe in.
The 'e-book, the vitamin,
the skinny tea, the app,
the service, the agency,
the cleaning service, the Uber of pillows...
Whatever they come up with,
the reason they're not good at selling
is 'cause they think they're
product is a piece of shit.
I just had the great fortune of
whether it's baseball cards rookies
or ?? that were up-and-coming
...or books or...
You know,  Vaynermedia itself.
I just always sold something I believe in,
which has allowed me to have passion,
be aggressive, have conviction,
and be successful at it.
So please,
before you worry about selling,
figure out if what
you're selling is worthwhile.
(French accent)
Landed in L.A.
Driving to the hotel.
Seems quiet in L.A. right now.
Long day.
Really long 24 hours,
But, part of the process.
Gotta love it.
That's kind of like the Snapchat photo
or Instagram story/photo I put up.
I've got more conviction than you.
I think one of the things that allows me...
A lot of people ask me what...
How do I have my energy?
Where do I get my energy...from?
and I always talk about gratitude, right?
A lot of you heard that answer.
Wondering how much comes from
the fact I believe so desperately
what I'm doing
in the companies that I built,
in the way that I'm impacting people,
in the actions of hacking culture
and communication platforms
and strategizing.
Is my conviction just so much
better than yours because I just
believe so much? No doubt.
No doubt in my body about
my execution,
my blueprint,
my intent,
and how this all ends up, and so...
That's what that little Instapost was about.
I just appreciate all of you guys going on this journey.
This is how you end a day, properly.
...after traveling for 24 straight hours. 😴
(uhhh....)
(Instrumental music)